what's our personal day eske book would
force it on a cell our digital imagery
pattern only first we see last year at
Gamescom we introduced you to wide our
first game as a new studio being
developed exclusively for PlayStation 4
we are a small team and a game is still
early in development but we really
wanted to share with you more details on
what you can expect from why
save her Shaymin ah
in order to save this clan member who
have been bitten by a snake one option
is to summon the mighty snake divinity
at the sacred place you can see in the
distance being as Shaymin you will learn
several ways of asking nature for help
like in this case how to call an eagle
but the most powerful shaman's can go
even further and enter a State of Trance
to take control of any animals each
creature in the world of wild has
special skills and abilities that we
help you survive in this harsh
environment this eagle has a very
powerful vision which will help you to
spot and catch more creature like those
snakes over there
which type of environment provides
specific resources on animals if we live
all different depending on the weather
time of the day and the seasons as you
can see my Eagle carries the snake for
me if I manage to build a relationship
with the wide animals I can let them
follow me in my journey and be a
powerful team well let's call a very
different animal now
the bear is a powerful ally that will
help me during challenging combats
it also very fast and friendly mount
which is quite handy to travel across
the vast and seamless world of wild
we finally reached a secret location
where I will be able to summon the snake
divinity in order to save my poison the
Python member of my clan but the
summoning all tasks can be surrounded by
dangerous tribes in this case a frontal
attack would be a bad idea
luckily I can use the wildlife living
here okay
let's attack that camp with a rabbit
the rabbit is very useful to stick into
this cannibal camp undetected
once again I can use the wide life
around me be creative and find my own
solution let's use those raisins now my
plan is to distract those crazy
cannibals this will give me an
opportunity for more direct attack let's
see if it works
the
now that the area is safe
I can finally reach the sacred sanctuary
there's a lot of places like that in
white and I have the freedom to choose
which one I want to use here I can
cement the divinity I want depending on
the type of animal I will bring the
snake divinity could teach me how to
make an antidote or control the snake
okay everything that you saw here the
path I took the approach for each
situation is on it's just an example of
what all the choices you can make
nothing is free written it's all
emergent we hope that every player will
have a unique story to tell in the world
of wild merci beaucoup